ce que vous feriez vous parce que
j'étais déjà posé la question tarek
mines en faisant suite qu'est ce que
vous feriez si vous reste trente jours à
vivre comme tarek lui dans ce film il a
choisi les travailleront et s'est dit je
vais vraiment je vais changer
j'ai changé ma personnalité gt peut
rejeter là je vais être un
voilà je vais dire je veux dire nico
boucle assez simple et diageo ce riad
aussi dans le film yaggeuse ryad aussi
avec toi que j'ai vu aussi à brahim
aussi exactement c'est ça voilà ouais
c'est vrai qu'il embrasse fort aussi
alors qu'est ce que vous feriez vous si
vous restez 30 jours avec castel niveaux
variés encore oui et non ouvrir les yeux
ou verizon 29 fois oui le divorce entre
en fait le jour d'accord tout cas vous
êtes très bonne je crois que j'ai qu'à
la reconquête de mon ex je les ai déjà
dit cyril dans cette émission qui m'a
quitté à cause de vous c'est vrai oui
mais non et non mécénat mais c'était
hyper longtemps il a loué je dirais pas
que sage permis de revenir là dessus
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
soyez quoi monsieur moi je retrouverai
tout ce qu'on dit que j'arriverai à rien
à faire dans la vie depuis la maternelle
ouais il faudra bien 30 jours et puis il
y en a beaucoup que vous irez voir
malheureusement père lachaise
aller à leur joie
l'humain n'est pas immortel ah oui oui
l'invité mystère feriez quoi tu bois tu
es toujours je serai marchande de sorbet
coco sur une île tropicale et dont on va
dire qu'il vous reste onze jours à vivre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous gérez des magnifiques spectaculaire
une maison barbecue barbecue avec ma
famille restera en vigueur ghezzal est
directement six ans michel wimax j'ai
mis longtemps à mettre en couple si vous
avez 30 jours à vivre
j'organiserai le plus beau des mariages
ah ouais donc tout faire si ils en
couple d'amis à robert on sait pas qui
c'est on espère la robin tu rajoutes
gilbert des moi j'essaierai de me
réconcilier pendant 30 jours avec tous
les gens avec lesquels je suis fâché a
beaucoup même mais ça vous améliorez
votre pizza d'eau et star serait jamais
voir michel cymes lardière lorànt
deutsch two way j'essaierai d'obtenir le
soft prend toujours ça suffirait pas
jean pascal moi je pars sur un golf
avant 30 jours je joue tous les jours
avec des cocktails d'accord on va vous
avez été autant chômeurs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
cyril est reconnaissant à tout le monde
franchement non mais j'ai site
ouest-france fr ou tre voilà trente
jours de direct et je fais des cadeaux
vraiment on essaie de régaler tout
meghraoui fait déjà n'ont vraiment pas
non mais non là vraiment et vous
jean-michel moi j'avoue c'est un peu
plus superficiel il aurait adoré de
vivre au moins une fois dans ma vie la
vie d'un milliardaire avec une yachts de
30 5 mai et 15 me sur le yacht des
belles voitures du champagne à gogo
donc du coup je vous colle aux basques
pendant 30 jours
[Applaudissements]
pour dire vous allez être bien déçue je
vous le dis vous avez bien déçu